d'où venez vous de ce quartier vous
comptez aider votre communauté
restez à votre place ne discutait jamais
alors oui bien sûr je jure ici je vous
garde au nom la coupure de courant de ce
soir nous force à transférer les
patients c'est vous qui serez de garde
de garde toute la nuit l'obscurité vous
effraie
j'aime bosser la nuit ils se passent
toutes sortes de trucs
c'est audard
[Musique]
j'ai été poursuivi par quelque chose à
ce stade je me suis retourné il y avait
personne derrière une infirmière digne
de ce nom et que don de soi et
sacrifices
et vous y êtes vous prête à donner
m
de turquie est un gardien
la lumière qui éclaire ma route
défends moi
il ya quelqu'un